I I'll give you the bad news and then
I'll give you the good news the bad news
is that actually every institution is so
thoroughly uh infused with Insanity you
know and our political structures in the
US are just so deeply corrupt I mean it
is fundamentally a racket um that they
also are more or less unrescued
and in fact it is constantly now being
targeted by people who understand that
it is an obstacle to what they want to
accomplish in terms of power but that
said both our parties are so deeply
corrupt that they I believe are both
unrescued
um and the same can be said of our
newspapers of the entire tech industry
you know you have uh started a
competitor to the major platforms and
you're doing very well and you've done a
great job of protecting speech so um
that's a beautiful thing but you're
still a small player and the big players
you know including unfortunately X you
know which is a mystery I would love to
see solved but nonetheless all of the
institutions frankly of the West are uh
in freef
Fall that's the bad
news Brett
Weinstein hello Dave Ruben it's very
good to be here with you I did not know
we would be seeing each other in London
but we're doing apparently a big Ruben
report jarie Reunion Show over the last
couple days um there's something I think
deeply interesting about what put you on
the map at everrain which everyone knows
about and the protests and the threats
of violence and now that you and your
wife hether no longer have jobs there uh
after dealing with the mob and what
we're seeing sort of burst across
Academia all over the West right
I suppose you were not that surprised No
in fact I rather how was that to tee you
up rather famously said that this was
going to spill out into the world and
that it really um was not about free
speech and it was only tangentially
about college campuses and that it would
eventually infect everything which it is
doing uh and it's a Pity that it had to
get to that stage for people to realize
that that was inevitable but I guess
we're here now and maybe maybe there's
still time to rescue something do you
think there's a time to rescue something
that well why don't we do the academic
level first before we get to sort of the
political of it which is what's
happening here yeah no you can't rescue
the academy it's unrescued
for so long that there aren't enough
people left in the academy who know how
to do the job properly right the number
of people most of those who did know how
to do the job properly either realized
that Academia wasn't the place to do it
and they never completed their degrees
or they were driven out and the people
who are there are largely there because
of an epidemic of cowardice that has
allowed them to dodge the the ire of the
the revolutionaries but do you really
want you know a faculty full of cowards
who can't manage to resist insane ideas
like 2 plus two might not equal for or
pedophilia might be a concept that we
have to reinvestigate or that you know
you know
Sciences discovered that men can become
women all of these things were insane
from the get-go so You' got a you've got
a faculty who even if they privately
know better won't say so those people
are not in a position to staff a
university that works I asked you this
the first time we ever sat down which
what when did the whole Evergreen thing
blow up just context for the audience
well
roughly um 9:30 in the morning May 23rd
2017 roughly okay so I had you on I had
you on I think you you were the first I
was the first interview did so it was
probably about that is true maybe four
or five days after that one of the
things that I asked you and I wonder if
your perspective has changed a little
bit is do you think that even you and
Heather should have seen it first I mean
you guys were at a wildly I think
Evergreen was considered are the most
Lefty college in America or the second
most Lefty obviously Pacific Northwest
Portland Seattle Washington Etc um do
you think that you guys should have seen
it first or done something earlier out
of the arms earlier that's a great
question and actually I was just
thinking about it yesterday um a we did
see it and in fact Heather and I uh
Heather and I have known each other
since high school uh we graduated from
UCSC together and we saw the parent
generation of this Insanity during our
our stinus college students and we did
fight back so we've been fighting it for
a long time I don't uh I don't think
that there is anything obvious we could
have done and we fought it on our own
campus at Evergreen in fact what the
public does not know is that 9:30 in the
morning May 23rd
2017 turns out to have been chosen by
the faculty who put the students who
streamed into my classroom and accused
me of racism students I should point out
that I had never met um The Faculty who
put them up to it chose that day because
it was the oneyear anniversary of my
standing up in a faculty meeting where
there were no students present and
fighting uh as the only voice who spoke
against a particular uh initiative in
which faculty were going to be forced on
an official document to Chronicle their
own racism annually so we did fight back
on the other hand there is a degree to
which after Heather and I got uh ejected
from the academy there was still um a
degree of it took time to actually see
the world with full clarity on the
outside yeah I I would imagine that if
you are a spy who adopts the language of
whoever it is you're spying on and lives
amongst them so that you can collect
information there's also an
inevitable uh uh picking up of belief
structures or ways of seeing the world
and when you find yourself back home it
must take some time to to regain your uh
your your full faculties and I think uh
there is a degree of that that some of
some of what was going on around us we
didn't see and some of it we saw very
very clearly but it's impossible when
you're embedded at that level to be
perfectly clear-headed so if you believe
that the acade uh the academic layer has
just sort of
disintegrated um what do you think about
the political layer I mean that's not
fully what Arc is about arc's really
trying to figure out what the story is
so that we can get it across disciplines
to fix some of this stuff but like
politically what do you think is
supposed to happen well here in America
wherever you want to go um I I'll give
you the bad news and then I'll give you
the good news the bad news is that
actually every institution is so
thoroughly uh infused with Insanity you
know and our political structures in the
US are just so deeply corrupt I mean it
is fundamentally a racket um that they
also are more or less unrescued
now in the case of the US structure we
have a constitution that's quite good
and in fact it is constantly now being
targeted by people who understand that
it is an obstacle to what they want to
accomplish in terms of power but that
said both our parties are so deeply
corrupt that they I believe are both
unrescued
of our newspapers of the entire tech
industry you know you have uh started a
competitor to the major platforms and
you're doing very well and you've done a
great job of protecting speech so um
that's a beautiful thing but you're
still a small player and the big players
you know including unfortunately X know
which is a mystery I would love to see
solved but nonetheless all of the
institutions frankly of the West are uh
in
freefall that's the Badness right I
don't think that they are rescuable um
you know and maybe even X is the
demonstration of this because I think
Elon actually did want to rescue it and
it's proving to be difficult um
extremely and he's admitting it to some
extent and I also think we guys try to
also send us to Mars and maybe spread a
little thin on some of this stuff yeah
there is there is there's a lot of stuff
but so that's the bad news is all of our
institutions are fatally compromised and
I'm not even
sure uh I'm increasingly wondering
whether or not um rescuing them is the
is the right metaphor um
but the um the good news is that the
force that I call Goliath has
taken almost every single player that
you could want on your team and shoved
them out of whatever institution they
were in and pissed them off in the
process so effectively Goliath has
created the dream team that you would
want to gather if you wanted to fight
Goliath well that's why these three days
have been so special to me personally
it's like all of these people I came to
KN know over all these years for all
these different reasons right the fact
that you just showed up at my doorstep
one day after going through what you
went through and it's like we're all
here now so maybe well it's time I mean
it's actually frankly late but it's not
too late as far as I know um so I I do
hope that the the proper thing gathers
I'm a little concerned uh I'll just be
frank with you um conservatives are
right about an awful lot these days we
have thrown out so so many babies with
the bathwater um and obviously that has
traveled on a carrier wave of at least
nominal uh
progressivism that the conservatives are
now seeing how right they were and
they're feeling Vindicated and I get it
but that said you cannot conserve your
way out of our predicament that we are
actually in a new place and our
dysfunctions are actually in part A
measure of the fragility of the
structure that we had so if we're going
to get out of this we can't just it
can't just be conservative yeah I agree
that we need to build new things and
conserve all things right which is Trick
which ironically is also a liberal
concept to some extent and this is the
thing you know and if you actually were
to go back and look at all of the places
where Jordan Peterson and I have
interacted this has been a constant
refrain between us and and he's been
great on it right I keep saying look
it's what he represents to me many the
tension between these things is what
makes it work the tension between the
the Liberals desire to solve problems
and the conservatives desire to prevent
us from doing stupid things that bring
about you know new dysfunctions that we
didn't even see coming can you give me a
biological example of what's happening
right now like is there a way to look at
an organism that has gone through sort
of like the systemic failure that you're
talking about that that ends up
Surviving I'm sure we can you give me a
lot that you know the the systems fail
and then the animal dies but is there is
there something sort of evolutionary
that that kind of works here um yeah yes
but it isn't what you're asking for it's
not like you know it's not like I can
point to sea otters and you know use
them as an example the example is people
um so let me just lay out the sort of
brief model and this is uh for people
who want to dive deeper this is in uh
the book that Heather and I wrote honor
gatherers Guide to the 21st
century human beings are different than
any other species that has ever existed
we have a specialty and our specialty is
having no specialty and the way we do
that we get the advantage of of a
specialist species and the advantages of
a generalist what's happened is that our
genomes have offloaded the work of
evolution the Adaptive capacity to our
cultural minds or to our systems
basically right is that it's really The
genome backed its own control off and
handed over the job of adaptation to our
cultural layer and because culture can
move horizontally it evolves at a rate
that is uh many many orders of magnet
ude faster so it can adapt to novelty
whereas your genes would take forever to
confront new problems so that's great
and what it means is that whereas most
species have a niche human beings can
have Niche after Niche we switch niches
as part of our mechanism for being
people now the way we do that is that
when we have when our ancestors wisdom
is functional which is most of the time
in history we just apply it and that's
the cultural packages we are handed the
religious doctrines that we have the
princip principles that our grandparents
told us when the ancestral wisdom fails
when it's inadequate either because
you've moved somewhere that they didn't
know anything about or because something
has changed what we do is we move into
Consciousness Consciousness is our tool
for dealing with novelty and so what
people misunderstand about Consciousness
is they think Consciousness is
fundamentally the thing that we all
experience in our own minds our
awareness that's secondary the primary
function of Consciousness is what we're
doing right now it's the thing that
humans uniquely do it is the the sinanan
of humans it is the ability to transmit
abstractions between minds and then
parallel process them and then come back
together with something that is greater
right it's the the sum is greater the
whole is greater than the sum of the
parts and that capacity is what we're
supposed to do when our ancestral wisdom
is inadequate so now think about the
description that you just gave of where
we are and the tension that you and I
both feel about the sort of conservative
View and the need to add something
liberal in order to actually mature into
a new story that actually is better well
that's what we're supposed to be doing
we are supposed to be gathering and
figuring out what part of the ancestral
wisdom still applies which part of it is
out ofd what we haven't discovered yet
that needs to be brought in we would
write stories and then Evolution would
turn them into myths myths that become
transmissible and then hopefully two
generations from now three generations
from now those people would have a
cultural package that did work because
we their ancestors had built it together
and put it into the cultural layer where
it can be transmitted efficiently to
them that's what we should be doing at
this moment because that's what human
beings do when the ancestral wisdom has
failed which is exactly where we are I'm
just reminded how good it is to sit with
you in person instead of when we've been
doing this on Skype lately because
there's a million other places I want to
go right now so we're going to do this
again in Miami and you are doing some
stuff with the santis on the co front so
we'll get you we'll get you to Florida
to do it properly but let me just ask
you one other thing so all of that being
said does it strike you that what is
happening right now was inevitable
meaning even if I don't mean about you
and Heather but if all of us had done
everything we could have done that no
matter what the system as it was
constructed was going to get us to this
point so that maybe we could have that
evolutionary sort of reset or or re
beginning um the full answer to that's
going to take two hours at some point
but but let me give you the brief answer
part of so we can then use it as a setup
for the next cool yeah part of this was
inevitable um and part of it I've been
predicting since I was a college student
and it's really dire if you understand
what it is and why it was inevitable the
West
is um the most beautiful invention that
humans have come up with because it
allows us to take our genetic drive to
exclude others who don't share our genes
and it replaces it with a better
fundamental reason for a civilization
and that is the creation of wealth by
collaborating right if you put aside
somebody's genetic relatedness to you
then you have a great range of people to
collaborate with and who knows what two
or three or 10 individuals might come up
with that we haven't had yet so it
generates wealth like crazy which is why
the West has been so contagious because
once you see how Dynamic and and
productive it is you want to
join problem is that system the West the
agreement to put aside genetic lineage
is fairer it is safer it is less violent
uh it is more it is it gives greater
chance to pursue meaning Beauty
compassion all the things that we want
to see in the world but it's fragile and
the problem is that when the growth runs
out when you stop being able to generate
growth because the next Frontier is not
obvious it breaks down into the prior
order which is lineage versus lineage
violence essentially what you're seeing
in the Middle East is that outbreak
which was inevitable but the problem is
because the world has now run out of the
mechanisms for generating growth or even
pretending that there is growth the
whole world is going to the West is
falling apart in front of our eyes as
predicted right it's interesting so
basically what we're saying is if we had
new places to explore even on planet
Earth that might be an Avenue for it
right or maybe we have to be this would
be an Elon version we have to be off
Planet if we just had other avenues to
do some of the stuff that humans are
kind of set up to do that may be some of
but we're we're sort of at the end of
the road in some respects our current
thinking and you I'll just put it in
very intuitive terms if you think about
it if you are in a place where there is
a growth potential then you got to be a
total dick to go after people because of
the shape of their nose or the color of
their skin right why go after people
when you can just bring stuff into the
world and make wealth out of it but when
there's no opportunity to do that the
natural thing is to figure out you know
it's musical chairs and suddenly the
music has stopped and you know it's not
that there's one chair too few it's like
30% of us are not going to be around so
who can I collaborate with to make sure
we get chairs and blood is thicker than
water that's why this is happening so if
you don't want to see a massive W wave
of anti-Semitism which of course we are
already seeing as predicted if you don't
want to see the world descend into these
factions in which they go after each
other because the music has stopped and
it's time to team up based on genes what
you need to do at this point I don't
even think we can rescue the West what
you have to do is rekindle it you know
the way the Ancients might carry a an
ember in a sack so that when they got to
a new place they could start a fire
without having to break out the bow
drill we need to rekindle the west from
that which remembers what it was and we
need to butress it so that it's actually
capable of not um running out its own
growth opportunities and if we don't do
that I'm afraid that we're it's not even
that we're being returned to this awful
phase of history from which we came we
can't do that with the weapons we have
it won't last right that's the other
thing throwing algorithms and new
weapons and now it's far worse right so
the the real point is look and I I don't
like saying this I don't like being an
an Us and Them kind of guy but
unfortunately the logic takes me there
it forces me to it this is US versus
them and us is anybody who gets why the
West is the answer to this puzzle and
anybody who doesn't get it I don't care
what flag they're waving those are the
people that we either have to bring on
board or figure out how to deal with
their opposition because they're in a
position to kill off this experiment and
by this experiment I mean the human
experiment I don't really try to end
into abuse on on a positive note but
since we agreed that this is just the
Prelude to a longer thing great to see
you my man great to seeing you if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop screaming check out our
politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell